volcanoes
they're a life-giver and they take life
away
they're extremely destructive and yet
they create new land
they create new atmosphere
[Music]
so everything from the water that forms
the oceans
and our hydrological cycles on earth was
released through volcanic eruptions
the heat that was supplied to the
surface environment
is largely from the interior of our
world
and so volcanoes have been tied to the
formation of our planet
the evolution of our planet and the
context of habitability from which
our very distant microbial ancestors
came from
so while they may seem rare now they
actually are an intrinsic part of our
planetary history
and our personal history as well
[Music]
iceland is located in a unique place on
earth
which uh combines two of the most
volcanically
active geologic locations on the planet
it's got the combination of
a mid-ocean ridge and really what that
is is a place where the surface of the
earth is being pulled apart
and if the surface is pulled apart then
all the magma from below can come up
we see that happening on other planets
we see
on mars places where mars has been
pulled apart
and the other thing this icelandic
eruption has going for right now is that
we discover that this particular lava
has a lot more magnesium in it
and there's strong indication that there
are magnesium-rich lavas on mars
there's also the fact that at least so
far this volcano is not
exploding we expect that
volcanoes erupting on other planets are
also not going to explode they're going
to have this sort of type of
volcanic eruptions this type of eruption
can potentially go on for a long period
of time
in the martian environment all the major
volcanic provinces
are dotted with these small volcanoes
we use iceland as an analog for
all the similarities that iceland have
with mars the geology and the rocks
have very similar to composition to
martian
assaults you try and get the composition
all the elements and minerals that you
find in any particular
of the salt and then that tells you
about
where the basalts come from i kind of
think it's like
it's like being a fortune teller or
something where if you read someone's
palm
you take you take a piece of basalt and
you kind of say like uh
you know much energy has happened here
like there was a terrible thing that
happened in the past
mars is smaller than the earth it
doesn't have plate tectonics what seems
to have happened is
it was hot in the beginning and then it
slowly cooled down
and now it's kind of mostly cool we know
from looking at the martian surface
that it was very different in the past
at least you know
3.84 billion years ago it has all these
river valleys all over the surface
it has big lake basins so we know
there was water all over the place it
would seem like a really nice place to
live
and then at some point it stopped being
so nice and all the water
either froze and sublimed or it
evaporated
it went into minerals and we don't see
liquid water on the surface today
what changed to make it possible for the
water to exist
and then what made it so that it no
longer exists there's a couple different
things but a big one is the volcanoes
at the beginning of martian history
there was lots of volcanism happening
so all these volcanism triggered
hydrothermal activity on the surface
which causes hydrothermal systems and
something very important is that there
is evidence of this
interaction between volcanoes and
glaciers
from orbital observation so what this is
telling us is that
it is very very likely that we have
hydrothermal systems on the martian
surface but also
they were potentially protected by a
layer of eyes
which could have been very important to
protect
any life from uv or other like really
harsh radiation
[Music]
life as we know it on earth we believe
requires the presence of liquid water
currently liquid water is not stable on
the martian surface
but we know that there's ice beneath the
surface
underground so if you had volcanic heat
melting some of that ice keeping it warm
suddenly you've got an environment that
is favorable
for her life
[Music]
there is evidence that there has been
volcanic eruptions within the last
couple million years
which for geologists is like yesterday
recently
an insight is a mission that's sitting
on the surface with the seismometer
and it's measuring marge quakes and it
actually measured a series of marsquakes
that seem to be coming from
these fissures called the cerberus
fossae and the cerber's fossae are the
origin of some of the youngest lava
flows on the whole planet
really pristine beautiful lava flows go
on and on for
maybe a thousand kilometers if
this rumbling that's taking place of
these fissures
people some people think that could be
because
if these fissures are still active and
the volcano is still alive
we've never seen a volcano erupt but
that's something that i would
just blow my mind if i saw uh an actual
live
lava flow going across the surface of
mars
mars in many ways is the most earth-like
of the planets in our solar system
and because of that it's a very
challenging environment but it also
seems familiar but oddly different so
the climate
extremes that mars has undergone from a
more idyllic early
period to a frozen wasteland that it is
now
that really gives us an idea of the
alternative futures that our world could
have had and the different phases of our
own history
so i think that one of the fantastic
things about analog research
is that we can look at locations on
earth to help us understand other
planetary environments
but by studying those environments we
actually learn something new about
our own world as well so understanding
volcanoes on other planets it's actually
telling us something about
how earth has lost its heat through time
how
earth's oceans and hydrologic cycle has
evolved through time
and there has got to be a connection
with biology
with life it's not a coincidence that
earth is the only planet with
this plate tectonics with lots of liquid
water on the surface
and abundant life so
why why is earth like that and volcanoes
are
part of that puzzle so that's the
fantastic part it's a
time capsule but it also lets us think
about our world differently
just as the first exploration of the
moon and that first wonderful image
looking back at the full globe of earth
really challenges us
to think differently about our global
environment and about our planet
[Music]
[Music]
you